here with more south carolina senator
lindsey graham
all right you've been saying it ted cruz
has been saying it senator kennedy's
been saying it
and senator rand paul's been saying it
and i credit all of you
it why let's start with the basics why
please tell me in the name of jesus in
heaven
why would we give china and their wuhan
lab of virology one single solitary
penny
let's start there well number one it
seems to me
china's got a lot of money they can pay
for their own research but the most
stunning thing out of your monologue to
me
was the idea that dr fauci doesn't
believe that it's in china's interest to
lie
about the leak from their lab the person
from nbc asked him
isn't it in their interest to lie to the
world and not admit it came from their
lab because i said make them look
terrible
if you can't figure that out then you've
got a real problem on your hand
candor and openness and transparency do
not go in the same sentence when it
comes to china
so what to do call dr fauci before the
senate
and the house allow the people in the
state department who were silenced
about pushing the lab leak theory to
have their say
hold those responsible who shut down
this conversation
make sure they're fired and get to the
bottom of what happened and finally
introduce sanctions bipartisan against
china if they don't cooperate with an
international community
they will never tell you the truth until
they're made to do so
he was told january 31st 10 days after
the first identified case of corona in
the u.s he was told
by the day that donald trump put in
place that xenophobic hysterical travel
ban that probably saved
countless hundreds of thousands of lives
uh the one that joe called xenophobic
hysterical and all that
um ten days in he was told
it looks engineered that that the
sequence of the virus
show every indication that in fact this
gain of function had happened
10 days in now the question is this is
why
we need good okay this is why we need to
call dr foucher before the
doesn't this remind you a little bit
about the dossier
yeah a lot was bad and they kept
why okay they knew it was bad but they
had an outcome they wanted which was to
blame trump right
well they shut down the idea that it
could have come from the lab because the
chinese scientists
will never admit to that because it
makes them look incompetent
and the american scientists who have a
working relationship
with the chinese scientists it would
make them look incompetent
we need somebody outside the science
world
to get to the bottom of this and i think
this is a job for congress
senator we now have evidence first we
played this tape many times joe biden
three separate occasions
i never talked to my son hunter about
his foreign business dealings not one
time
never now we've got pictures uh
of joe in restaurants with oligarchs
from kazakhstan ukraine russia et cetera
et cetera
does america now have to worry that the
chinese
have compromising material on the biden
family
because in my view there's no rational
reason that
that the president would give a waiver
for putin to build his pipeline while
taking away american jobs and american
energy
independence on the other hand it
doesn't make any sense why
goldman sachs and deutsche bank and jp
morgan and
and chase that they didn't get the
1.5 billion dollar deal with the bank of
china that
hunter got it the crack addict so you
explained to me do we have to worry
about this administration compromise
because if it was donald trump as
president that would be the narrative
every single second
hour of every 24-hour day
absolutely sean because you have
irrational business relationships
why would a bank in china give hunter by
money except for the fact
that he has connections to vice
president biden
why is he on burisma's board in the
ukraine if he doesn't know anything
about the oil and gas business
because of his last name and the fact
that vice president biden was in charge
of rooting out corruption in the ukraine
it defies
common sense that these are normal
business deals is it illogical to think
that somehow due to his activity in the
ukraine and china
he may have been compromised i can
guarantee if a republican
president's son had done this or a vice
president republican vice president son
had done these things
be front page news all over the world
and you ask a good question
uh has he been compromised
what explains allowing russia to build a
pipeline
and you shut one down in your own
country how does that make sense
well it doesn't uh you just got back
from israel real quick because summary
because i see nothing but an unmitigated
disaster
a weak american president and no bb on
the world stage
yeah well bb don't count him out
but no matter what happens the right the
middle and the left in israel
they're very worried about the iran
nuclear deal they hate the jcpoa
and here's what biden is doing he's
going to create a nuclear arms race if
we go back into the reiner agreement
because the arabs are going to want
their own enrichment capability
and then we'll have a nuclear arms race
secondly israel will not tolerate an
enrichment program in iran
uh we're headed for a war between israel
and iran if we go back in the jcpoa
we're going to have a nuclear arms race
between the arabs and and the iranians
and you're going to put israel in a bad
spot where you'll have a war between
iran
and israel if we go back into this bad
deal and i heard that from everybody in
israel not just bibi
all right senator great to see you thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else